okay all right up next is Roger in a
little rock hey Roger what's up hey Dave
thanks so much for taking my call I
appreciate it sure how can I help so I
live in areas of the state where there
are just a lot of full-time ministries
lots lost a lot of full time missions
organizations you know meeting a lot of
the people who work for those
organizations attend my church and many
that were good friends of mine me too so
naturally naturally I get a lot of
questions about hey can we meet to talk
about
yeah I'm possibly he's helping support
me monthly yeah me too yeah and I'm debt
free and that's a great thing and you
know I want to be generous and also have
in the earlier stages of my career I've
only been out of college for a little
over two years yeah so I just can't say
yes to everything and I guess my
question is how can I say no to some of
these opportunities without while also
affirming the work they're doing and
also yeah just not leaving them
discouraged when somebody tells them no
yeah well then being discouraged when
somebody tells them no as part of their
life it's what they chose they're in a
non-profit they raise money they get a
lot of nose okay yeah you're right I'm
in the same situation dude I live in
Nashville we're more Baptist here than
people okay I mean it's just like we're
the buckle of the freakin Bible Belt
right so yeah and everybody's got a
ministry idea and a lot of them are
really good legitimate ideas yeah and
it's pretty cool and immediately when
you like put financial peace on the
front of something they think that they
need some financial peace from us and so
so and we give a lot my daughter runs
our our family foundation and that's how
we do all of our giving except our
church tithing through that and so but
you know her job a lot of her job is
just no no we can't it's not in the
budget this year it's not in the budget
now that's one thing you can do let me
tell you emotionally how to do it though
because more that's more what you're
struggling with anything else well yeah
when I keep saying yes to everything
that's good when someone wants some of
my time and I get overbooked you know
cause I'm trying to help everybody you
know what I'm saying
it's kind of the same thing it's your
time and your money right my wife always
looks at me and goes hey you're not
Jesus
that's your that's his job so get over
your Messiah Complex he's gonna help him
you can't help everybody you can only
help how many you can help and if you
spend yourself so thin you can't help
anybody well and the same is true with
our money isn't it oh yeah you're not
Jesus there's more needs than you got
okay
way more hungry children than Rodger can
feed mm-hmm and so your giving is
between you and the Lord about what he
wants you to do with the money he gave
you to manage for him and so spend time
in prayer get over your Messiah Complex
it's not up to you to support everybody
I'm talking like my wife now dude okay
and but it's not it's the same thing
right you're not you're not Jesus that's
his job and then just smile and go it's
not my budget I have a budget forgiving
and me and the Lord have worked that out
and I've already did I've already
committed all of that this year and so I
can't do it I'll pray for you I really
think what you're doing is awesome and
if you want to talk about any time come
over here but I'm not gonna be able to
be one of your funding sources this year
maybe another time maybe not but this
year I can't because it's not in the
budget and you just smile and pray for
them and say no because you're not Jesus
and I had to get there myself it's a
tough thing but I'm not pretty easy for
me to know that but anyway this is the
Deb Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you